Oh Mia hello darling I just wanted to
make sure that you're okay yeah I'm fine
and that you knew you were talking out
loud you could hear me just that last
part about Lily good it's adorable but
we're trying to contact headquarters up
here and it's a little distracting
gotcha
so embarrassing
this is agents 93 little busy right now
no time for camp business this is not
can't business Herndon this concerns the
kidnapping it's that Herndon Forsythe
albury wants all the glory for this
rescue himself this is no time for
politics a man's life is at stake Shh
well we'll just have to locate Truman on
our own I'm just really worried about my
dad why would someone want to kidnap him
oh man is that what I look like hang on
that's better
wow I'm seeing the world from mia's
point of view I can't believe I'm on a
mission alongside my childhood hero
Sasha 9 don't mess this up Rasputin wow
so this is how sasha sees the world well
not usually from so high in the air but
yes obviously me a suitcase yeah do you
really think this is the time some
people think that telekinesis is a
little show but it's really the psychics
bread and butter
are you trying to hug me or something
knock it off
oh did the squirrels get in here again
that's to be expected when you park a
plane in the woods darling I told
headquarters an underground hangar pays
for itself in two years well let's think
of it as a mascot
Rasputin sorry
wow this stuff is super light not a
problem i'll double up just hand it to
be quick thanks for the reinforcements
son
I am the master of pillay's stop burning
stuff back there well it's not me Wow
toilet paper is really flammable you're
burning it we got a man down in here man
toilet paper is fun to blow up hey I
need that
something's not right this isn't good
rasputin darling can you hear me I'm
protecting the ship's controls too late
we need to focus on busting our
seatbelts
ah nothing like a little turbulence to
get the bowels moving all right like a
hawk why is Nielsen coming at us
Kamya I need to tell you something